[موسيقى]
ان الوالده لا زالت موجوده الله يعطيها
العمر والصحه
والها خصوصيه عاليه هاي المراه مو
اعتياديه هاي ام عدي وقصي ومرت الرئيس
صدام مو وارد انه نطرح اسمها كل شوي ومراه
لم تعد صغيره بالعمر
وتريد ترتاح
واطلاقا ما نضعها في حوارنا ولا نزعجها
ولا نذكر اي شيء يخصها
[موسيقى]
الحياه ادوار
ورفوف
كل شخص عنده رفض هذه الحياه يضع نفسه عليه
البنات
تعبوا كثير وشافوا كثير هاي العائله من
اقول لك هاي العائله احكي عن والدي والدتي
واحنا الخمسه الاخرين كل من يحكي عن حاله
هاي العائله شافت كثير
ومسؤولياتهم كبيره اتجاه اولادهم كلهم
عندهم عوائل وعندهم اولاد
فهم مشغولين بعوائلهم واحنا لازم نحترم
رغبتهم هذه احنا مو في زمن الديمقراطيه
لازم الاخرين
يحترمون رغبتنا رغبه خواتي او اي شخص من
العائله حتى الاحفاد ما المفروض نصلي
الضوء على شخص هو مو رايد يتسلط الضوء
عليه
كل واحد يرسم حياته بالطريقه اللي تريحه
[موسيقى]